so yesterday donald trump flew to north
carolina i covered it live
uh on our various live platforms the new
strategy
appears to be straight up indefensible
lies
that are totally divorced from reality
no longer even trying to couch the lies
as being even remotely or plausibly
believable
trump was asked about the fact and it is
a fact that he's behind in the polls
nationally and he's behind in important
states
and trump just responds i'm winning
everywhere and he doesn't just say i'm
winning everywhere and leave it at that
trump actually lists states in which he
claims he is winning despite what the
polls say
take a look at this visibly sweaty
donald trump
lying uncontrollably once again mr
president your call number
suffered in recent months because of
your handling on the pandemic you're
here now today
what's your plan going forward to prove
to americans that you're the right
person
i think the poll numbers are very good
uh the poll numbers we have are very
good we're leading in north carolina
we're leading in pennsylvania we're
leading in arizona our numbers
we're leading in arizona we're leading
nicely in florida i think our poll
numbers are very good
we're leading substantially in georgia i
mean uh
we get a lot of suppression polls we get
a lot of fake polls just like we have
fake news i mean it's a terrible thing
when you look at it but i had the same
thing four years ago
now i've said listen today i've spent
what a bunch of the show
reminding you trump can win yeah trump
can win but here he is simply lying poll
numbers
are good i'm leading in north carolina
he says he's leading in pennsylvania
arizona florida in georgia substantially
the numbers right now averages in these
states are that
biden's up by four in arizona biden's up
eight in florida
which is incredible trump is up by three
in georgia i don't know that's
overwhelming but he's up by three
biden's up eight in michigan biden's up
three in north carolina biden's up seven
and six
in pennsylvania and wisconsin
respectively so
of course donald trump is lying but my
question is is this a good strategy for
trump from the standpoint of get out the
vote and what i mean by that is
if trump's followers believe trump the
polls are fake and trump's winning
aren't they less likely to go out and
vote in other words if you want trump to
win
are you not more motivated to get out
and vote
if you believe trump may actually lose
your state now i'm not
giving them advice i'm thinking out loud
wouldn't trump be better off
saying something like we are taking the
campaign seriously in
every state i plan to fight for every
state because
i think i'm better for the people of all
of these states than my opponent
rather than saying we're actually
winning because it seems to me that
saying we're actually winning
might suppress his own turnout i just
don't understand the strategy and maybe
it's not really strategy it's just
trump's personality trump's narcissism
and trump's delusions of grandeur that
force him to do this
now later on during the same event trump
hilariously says
how could i be losing florida there's a
whole bunch of boat owners
in a man-made lake that have trump flags
that they are flying proudly take a look
when you look at florida as an example
you have thousands of boat out about
boats out of the ocean out on the
intercoastal
you look at other states where likewise
you have thousands of
boats and they're all waving the trump
sign
trump pence sign and they're so proud
thousands and thousands you've seen it
where you have bikers for trump with
lines that are miles long on highways
going along
on weekends i think there's more spirit
now
than there's ever been for my campaign
and that includes 2016 where obviously
there was great enthusiasm great spirit
we had
great spirit i think there's more today
because
what we've done nobody's ever done
before nobody has ever
rebuilt the military cut taxes the most
in our history
created the greatest economy we've ever
had
the focus on bikers and boaters is just
weird maybe trump doesn't understand
polls versus anecdotes i don't know
uh one other key moment from this short
question and answer period that trump
did and tr this is a common thing
trump has brought back the coronavirus
press briefings but he takes
very few questions very very few and of
course he never
actually answers them trump was asked
you know when you spoke to vladimir
putin earlier today
did you bring up the russian bounties
and of course
donald trump would not say
you did talk with russian president
vladimir putin and
i wanted to ask if you did bring up the
reports
of russia having bounties on
our soldiers and africans we don't talk
about what we discussed but we had
plenty of discussion
and i think it was very productive
please trump offhandedly just dismisses
it as i don't talk about what we've
discussed
that's not true i mean often you do and
often there are
readouts where we learn what it was that
was discussed
and in this case trump isn't saying what
i'm hearing is
no donald trump did not call vladimir
putin out
about russian bounties obviously and
that story has been very well buried
i've posted on twitter
a few times over the last month what
exactly happened with the russian bounty
stories
the responses from the right tend to be
something about a conspiracy i i don't
know it's obama committed some crime
tends to be the response not very
coherent but the story
has actually been successfully buried
and we are going to make an effort
not to allow that to persist make sure
you're following the david pakman show
on instagram
at david pakman show i really am overdue
for a new urban garden tour
my zucchinis are out of control i've got
10 inches
eight inchers out there i've actually
already picked one it's crazy
my cukes are starting to come in my
tomatoes are
like nothing anybody in my backyard has
ever seen before
follow me on instagram at david.pacman
for the latest
from the urban garden if you care about
that sort of thing otherwise right after
this short break
coleman hughes joins me next for what i
am sure
will be a very interesting discussion
let me tell you real quick about one of
our sponsors cuts
clothing they offer super quality men's
t-shirts and they're giving you 15
percent off
when you go to davidpakman.com cuts
that's
c-u-t-s because solid color
t-shirts are a really important staple
in pretty much every guy's wardrobe
i think it's really important not to
overlook the value of having t-shirts
you love wearing
t-shirts from cuts clothing have been a
game changer for me and as a company all
they deal with
are men's solid color t-shirts so they
actually put a ton of thought into the
comfort the style the durability of the
t-shirts they make
they fit perfectly they're not scratchy
they don't shrink they don't fade they
don't stretch out over time like so many
other t-shirts they're really the most
comfortable t-shirts i've owned
and they look great this right here that
i'm wearing
uh on youtube is the split hem
crew neck t-shirt very soft
fits me perfectly it's the ideal length
go take a look at what they offer and
once you have it
you are really going to see and feel the
difference
their slogan is it's the only shirt
worth wearing
you will see why and you'll get 15 off
when you do it
by going to davidpakman.com cuts
that's davidpakman.com c-u-t-s